Ever since I can remember I had the
dream to start my own organic soap
company. That was the reason why I took
this job in the first place. But there I
was working in the marketing department
of a big brand as a junior administrator
and instead of being excited to work for
this famous company I was frustrated
about how things were handled. I felt
completely lonely with my ideas to make
a positive impact. I spent the entire
next weekend studying different pitch
formats. I figured that it would be best
to follow the requirements of one of the
big startup accelerators if I could
pitch to one of them I could certainly
pitch to the marketing director. I opted
for a pitch deck which is based on the
following six elements: the problem, my
solution, the business model, the market
the competition, our team. Okay so the
problem: well most body soap brands not
only lack a truly refreshing smell but
more importantly they also sell in cheap
throwaway plastic containers which often
lasts not more than a month. New modern
consumers however see body soap as a
lifestyle choice and they want to have a
solution that not only works but also
smells incredibly refreshing and is
environmentally friendly my solution I
call elements it's an organic soap which
comes in four fantastic flavors water
sky earth and fire in the first order
customers get all four flavors and a
beautiful glass jar and with a click of
a button they get refill packs sent to
their home in sustainable carton
packages
the business model is the result of our
understanding of the lifetime value of a
customer my customers will be very loyal
as they made a clear lifestyle choice to
buy it the first purchase someone makes
is therefore just seen as an investment
we make into a long lasting relationship
it will cost customers 25 US dollars and
they get a beautiful glass jar and the
trial set of all four flavors the money
we make later from selling the refill
packs and sustainable paper bags for 15
US dollars similar to the famous razor
and blades business model the market is
enormous in the beginning we will target
urban women aged 20 to 30 years living
in the United States they are
well-educated they care about the
environment and are interested to
express themselves through lifestyle
choices based on my research they spent
on average around 50 to $100 on body
soap each year as there are around 15
million women in the US who are in their
20s living in urban areas the total
market opportunity is at least 750
million dollars a year once we capture
some of that we will expand to other
consumers and go global our competition
are big brands they own the market and
they've been telling consumers over the
years that body wash comes in a cheap
plastic bottle which ends up in the
ocean or on a landfill smaller startups
like ours might compete with them in
some segments but we rather consider
them as allies as we fight for the same
thing educating consumers to make a
switch to a more sustainable soap the
team that's me and my brother who
currently studies biochemistry but soon
he will have his degree and since he's a
real nature freak he is full on board to
help me develop a winning formula my
strengths are communication organization
and a clear understanding of what girls
my age want it took me until Sunday
night until I had what I thought was the
perfect pitch
few days later in the office I saw the
marketing director and took the
initiative I asked him to give me three
minutes of his time so I could pitch to
him but instead of hearing me out he
just said why don't you pitch it next
Monday at the board meeting the old guys
are always open for new ideas from the
young people within the company maybe
they will fund a prototype and do a
market test then he added with a smile
the biggest secret of getting funding is
this ask for money you'll get advice ask
for advice and you'll get money I was
completely blown away I should present
my idea to the board and I knew exactly
what to ask for I couldn't sleep that
night I was too excited about what the
marketing director had told me the next
morning when I went through my pitch
again I wasn't sure if I was really
prepared I called my former teacher he
had already started several successful
companies
the next day we met and I pitched my
idea to him after he listened to me my
teacher got really excited and said if
they don't buy your idea on Monday I'll
offer to finance you to get started
oMG I was so excited and so thankful on
my way home I reflected on my situation
I wondered if I really want to pitch to
the board and carry on working for the
same company which makes me feel
miserable after all I only worked there
to gain enough experience to start my
own business I realized that actually I
don't want someone else to buy and sell
my idea I want to try making it myself
it was clear to me that this is my
chance to finally get started I called
my manager thanked him for his time and
told him I'll quit my job to start my
own thing
how about you did you ever try to pitch
your business idea
write down your idea and follow the
different stages like described in this
video and post it in the comments below
or even better why not make a proper